connor dunham welcome to simulation
thanks it's great to be on
i'm excited for the conversation
i
met connor very recently just a couple
days ago
and
connor and jordan
jordan rain has uh been a friend of mine
seven
years now
very close friend and connor and jordan
co-founded
soulbound labs
yeah
and so we're gonna be talking about
decentralized reputation
and we were having a good
conversation about the importance of
this
um
i want to actually give a little bit of
backstory before we go to the example
you were sharing on the porch
sure because i think it's very relatable
for the audience which is
rather than taking
the existing style of governance which
in many ways is like plutocracy
governance by the wealthy to be able to
buy voting power
and pasting that into web3
into blockchain crypto etc
because right now
it
is
coin or token
based
governance voting
so we had an example just happened a
couple weeks ago where
beanstalk
had a flash lone attack
where
there was a
a malevolent actor that took out a
massive loan of
of beanstalk's
token
and then
hijacked the voting power the governance
to take out
uh
182 million dollars out of their
treasury and then
within 10 minutes they did that whole
process and returned the loan
um
and they got 80 million dollars through
that process
and
and i don't know thousands of people
lost tens of thousands of dollars or
something it was it was a lot of people
that were like what the
um
and so what vitalik buterin has been
talking about for a while now has been
moving beyond coin based or token-based
governance and one of the big things
that conor and jordan are pioneering
here is
reputation-based governance or
merit-based governance
on-chain activity or events being
rewarded
through
non-transferable nfts or badges or soul
bound
um
badges
so a little bit of backstory of where
we're going with web3 with what you guys
are building so at least that and then
now i would love for you to also take
over share anything of what i just uh
said about uh play on that and we can
also talk about what you were sharing on
the porch as a good way to bridge this
into the mainstream sure yeah i think
the the beanstalk uh example is a great
way to kind of like
uh explain why it is that we are
developing new forms of governance uh
it's not really a problem with the the
smart contracts it's not like there's a
bug in the
beanstalk smart contracts it's just the
the governance system that they're using
how to flaw in it where someone can take
out a flash loan and then exploit some
contracts
um
so this is a very hot topic right now in
web3 and lots of lots of people are
spending their energy working on this
problem
um
i was introduced to
the graph and
subgraphs about a year ago
and i realized that
if you could get this information that a
subgraph picks up and put it back on
chain then you could use it as a
as a form of governance
that it cannot be bought so you can
actually
uh give the governance power to the
people that have actually done the
things that
are beneficial to the wider community or
the protocol or whatever it is that is
being voted on
yeah
yeah okay
um yeah so there's a good thread to pull
there um
and maybe i'll just table that because
it already started going into sub graphs
and
just for a bit because i we will get
there
i want to also have you mention the very
relatable example that you were sharing
with me on the patio about uh the way
that today we look at linkedin
and what
how we feel like that will look in the
future
yeah so right now uh you know we if you
want to
advertise what you've done in your past
because you want to you know
get awesome jobs you you post your
employment history up on linkedin or
something like that
and
it's a interesting process because you
know no one's fact-checking
checking anything there like you can you
can make things up and people do all the
time and then they get interviews and
maybe the interview goes well maybe
doesn't but
um the bottom line is that it's all
self-reported most of the time
and then the second side of that is
you're sharing your data with this this
company and if they they go away or you
know they can
use your data to their benefit
um
so a new system
that kind of takes advantage of
blockchains and web 3 could be built
where
you can verifiably claim that you
did things in the past so you
contributed towards certain protocols or
you maybe you were a user of protocols
it can even just be for
you know making a certain number of
trades on a decentralized exchange or
whatever it is so
anyone can come up with a new
uh criteria for what
uh constitutes a badge
and then publish that in a
permissionless way
and then
the people that satisfy that criteria
criteria can then
claim an nft that is non-transferable
and therefore cannot be uh bought and
there there could be
voting power attached to that
um
it's optional so it there doesn't have
to be voting power attached to it but
we imagine that uh
a governance structure that uses this
kind of
non-transferable voting power has some
benefits to it and it doesn't
necessarily have to be 100
badge-based governance and zero coin
voting there are balances there and
there could be uh
you know you could take the best of both
worlds and utilize them both too yeah
and move be even beyond it to something
that's gonna include a third or fourth
element and stuff like that that's an
unknown right now which is which is cool
this is like the first push let's say
beyond just solely coin or token based
voting
um
what you just shared they're super
powerful because we're all
very
relatable example of going and looking
on uh linkedin or basically even
instagram or
wherever because what's happening is
people are using
social media or the internet as an
extended phenotype of themselves
portraying out
to the social sphere
their merits
right and so the idea is now can when i
see somebody saying something on their
linkedin or on their instagram about
their proficiencies
uh their skills how do we
verify
and it's through um on-chain events as
to how to be able to verify this in the
future like that thing that you're
saying that you did on linkedin
we're just putting that in a verifiable
way
on chain
and then we're able to uh have a
non-transferable nft
that you
um
have on your portfolio
uh let's say
and then that verifies that
the thing that you're writing on your
linkedin or your instagram uh in the
past and like web 2 you were writing it
that you did it but now in web 3 you
have a badge
that is a direct correlate of an
on-chain event
right exactly yeah and it could be a
collection of events maybe you have to
do something many times or maybe you
have to do five different things that
emit five different events and once
you've done all those things then you
get a badge yeah that kind of thing yeah
this is
so this is the cool like um
way to understand this i would say for
the mainstream like a mainstream
perspective of understanding this i
would say this is one of the most
friendly ways is like
man like web 3 is going to be about
badges
to correlate to on-chain events that are
non-transferable they're soul bound and
that i'm going to have a collection of
soul bound
badges
and that
those are going to correlate to not only
single events on chain but like you said
multiple events on chain so over a
period of five months if i do
the
thing one time per month
uh and after five months check mark then
i get said badge that's right so there's
yeah that's cool
i love that i love that it's uh it's a
very powerful
way to visualize
uh reputation and merit
and then uh i like another thing you
said which is crucial is then
it's
merit-based access control or
reputation-based voting
yeah
yeah i think that there are a lot of uh
a lot of benefits to having sort of
reputation-based voting uh that's going
in line with a token-based governance
model because
the interesting thing about interesting
thing about governance is
it's not necessarily a bad thing if
people are not participating in
governance you know if
if you don't need to contact your
congressman
then you can kind of assume that things
are doing pretty well right like if
people don't need to talk to their
government officials then things are
going well so it's hard to tell when you
know people are just not voting because
they're lazy or if they're they're
voting because they
are not informed or whatever it is
but usually with uh web 3 protocols
especially there's like a kind of a
smaller group of people that are have
like a larger stake in it maybe they're
actually spending their time working on
this thing
and then there's people that are
interested in it from like an investment
angle
and
the ability to kind of have more say
if you have skin in the game
i think is pretty valuable
and i think it's something that a lot of
web3 projects will be moving to in the
next few years
nice yeah
all right venture us into the
sub graph so what you started unpacking
earlier sure so
um a sub graph uh so this this is coming
out of the graph protocol um a sub graph
is a
it's kind of like
a set of instructions on how to index
the blockchain
so
once you have a set of instructions that
tell you how to index the blockchain
you can have different parties these are
called indexers
uh
index the blockchain according to that
set of instructions and then
they can serve queries to people that
are uh interested in
accessing that that information in a
decentralized way because if everybody's
agreeing that we're all indexing
according to the same set of
instructions
then we should all be uh responding to
queries in the exact same way and so the
graph has a whole system for
how to handle uh queries that are
query responses that are incorrect
basically the grt token is
staked by indexers and if they
respond to queries
incorrectly they can get slashed so they
lose some of their grt stake
uh so yeah that's how sub graphs work
and
i guess the realization that we had at
soulbound labs is that a a sub graph
could be used as kind of a
almost like a roll-up uh
so you can
bundle up a bunch of interesting things
that happened on the blockchain
uh
condense it into like a 32 byte hash or
something really really small and then
put it back on the blockchain
with the attestations from the indexers
so that
people can look at that
that thing that you post on chain and
know that it's legitimate because a
bunch of people are staking grt and they
could get slashed if they're lying about
it
so it's almost a form of like an
optimistic roll up in a way
all right
so
indexing
is
a specific style of
the data
on chain
indexing is storing data on chain in a
specific way
uh not quite so the the data's already
on chain it's just
uh
organized in ways that are not conducive
to humans
so indexing is organizing
on chain data exactly yeah all of the
data is uh publicly available anyone
could look at the blockchain and come to
the same conclusions that the indexers
are coming to so right now if i look at
an ethereum block
it's not
organized uh it's organized according to
standards that are you know meant for
other smart contracts to read
yeah right okay yeah yeah okay yeah and
then um
indexers further organize right okay and
the main use case for this right now uh
things like uh the uniswap dashboard
that just displays all of the you know
trading volume of all the different
pairs and stuff like that
that's built using sub graphs so on the
back end they have a sub graph they're
querying to come up with all the data to
display on the website
okay so
indexers are further organizing the data
on chain
and then
they're making that
able to
be
queried
okay so the
idea of like
the of the graph not of subgraphs but of
the graph is
to
be able to uh
make the
data on
chain
queryable retrievable
for those that
desire it
and then
to make like an inclusive stakeholder
process
so that indexers are incentivized for
good behavior to return
the correct
yeah data yeah exactly
yeah the graph protocol is i mean their
end game is to create a decentralized
marketplace for for data
and it's not quite there yet because
there's there's still
the decentralization side has a ways to
go i'd say but
um it's a great vision
and i i really hope it plays out i'm
happy to be contributing towards this
kind of thing
yes
and now
um
so sub graphs
uh
are
is it a way of
um visualizing
indexed
what indexers are doing
a way of visualizing it like is it is
our sub graphs
a way of visualizing what is happening
on chain
the data on chain that indexers are
organizing
um
i suppose you could put it that way but
it's still like it's still all just
numbers right there's no there's no ui
there these are literally just like
queries to a database so usually
um yeah in its current form the most
common thing you'll see
being used with with subgraphs are you
know dashboards that kind of display
data about certain protocols
okay
and so then how do you envision uh sub
graphs
in the process that we're describing and
what is role and how do you roll up
uh like reputational or merit based data
yeah
that kind of uh
yeah so
okay so if a sub graph uh
defines
the criteria for
uh
earning a badge then it can
it can roll up all of the badges that
have been earned
into
an encrypted
an encrypted hash that is like very
small
okay am i losing you we're i love this
we're going to break this down by piece
okay
so the sub graph is uh
the
um
like what would be required
as on shane behavior
to earn a badge
that's defined within the subgraph
that's defined within the subgraph yeah
it's not the whole subgraph but it's
part of it okay yeah
interesting so then each
uh dao or each community
is
designing their own sub
um
and then
depend and then the on-chain behavior of
of agents
uh
then
depending on what the dow wrote as their
subgraph would then reward those agents
with
the community's badges
yes yeah exactly and then
just to add one more thing there the
criteria for earning a badge doesn't
have to be baked into the subgraph it
could change like you can deploy a sub
graph and then the sub graph can listen
to a smart contract to see if any new
badge criteria
should be tracked and that's what you
guys call foundry
um
[Music]
foundry
it would be like uh
that's what we're referring to as like
uh like our governance uh
that badge based governance so so when a
dao wants to update their subgraph i
thought you guys were calling that
foundry
oh yes right so yeah if the governance
determines that they want to update the
subgraph which would mean that the
subgraph needs to track new events or
new you know new stuff then yeah foundry
that's faster cool
so that's um
yeah one of the ways that uh
that's how that's
what soulbound is calling that
functionality
is the foundry component to it dao is
updating the sub-graph
um
tracking new uh on-chain
events to then give their community
members badges
um okay so that was the first part of
what you shared was trying to understand
one part of subgraphs is monitoring on
chain behavior of agents and then
rewarding uh those agents with badges
right okay and then what was the second
thing you said about
oh the
uh get getting that information back on
the blockchain
i think um so yeah so a subgraph it can
award badges but those badges are just
existing
in the well really indexers right so as
as i would get the badge then that data
also needs to be placed on chain is that
what you're saying yeah it doesn't need
to be placed on chain but we feel like
there's significant demand for it to be
on chain there's also cool things you
can do without putting it on chain okay
oh wow yeah okay so that's another
component to sub graphs so it's yes two
so far
yeah and that so
getting the the data from the sub graph
and putting it back on chain is kind of
uh a technical
problem that popped up for us kind of
from the get-go really we initially
planned on using chain link
as an oracle service to
get information from a subgraph and put
it on chain but we felt like it was a
complete overkill
and that this could be done better by
using
attestations from
the graphs dispute process because they
have a really good
setup for slashing indexers that respond
to queries incorrectly
oh so can indexers also
put um
subgraph data on chain
then
they could yeah okay so yeah really any
so
it could be set up many different ways
and
theoretically it could be permissionless
where literally anyone can
query the subgraph for the latest state
of the rollup
and when they query the decentralized
network
they get a response back and they get an
attestation back from an indexer okay
and so if you just post both of those
things the response and the attestation
and the query to a smart contract
then the data could eventually be used
once it's been sitting there for long
enough that people agree that oh it's
been here long enough and no one's
disputed this so it's got to be true
so it does take that extra step of
everyone agreeing how long does this
need to
to be here before we can start
extracting data out of it and then after
that window
is up
then essentially you have this tiny bit
of data
that you can extract badges from by
providing proofs to a smart contract
and the way we imagine this working uh
at least initially with soulbound labs
is that
we will literally just mint all of the
the badges
for
maybe for a dow like if a dial wants to
have badges for their users
we would mint all of them on a layer two
because it's very cheap and as long as
you understand the subgraph code and you
kind of understand the protocol that
you're making reputation for you have
some kind of idea of how many badges
will probably be awarded or at least
some kind of upper bound like oh we
can't commit to minting five billion
badges on polygon even if it's one cent
right because it's just too
expensive so
there's that side of it as well like you
have to know
how many of these badges will come into
existence and
whether or not a centralized party is
willing to mint all of them or if you
want to keep it decentralized where like
like for example
maybe
if there's no party sitting there
minting badges for everybody
and i did something that's badge-worthy
maybe i could query a sub-graph and then
just post the response in the
attestation to a smart contract myself
and of course
there's there's not actually a lot of
technical know-how behind that if you
have a nice web app where you just click
buttons and it does it for you like it
sounds scary because it's like oh
individuals are querying a subgrab why
would i want to do that uh but really
like it it could be a good uh use case
for people that want to opt in to their
reputation instead of
having someone just
summarize all of their history and put
it on chain without their permission you
know
oh man this is so good
okay
so
trying to keep breaking this down in
digestible ways so
so
is
what is a
in this process with subgraphs and data
that's on chain
uh the roll-up is basically
you know you're taking
well you're asking like what is a
roll-up in general or for for
this use case like a sub graph acting as
a roll up
if i understand is rolling up just
compressing data
yeah essentially and it's uh
it is also
ordered so it's
it's additive like
you can't
uh
in other words like you can't remove a
badge like once
once something has happened
the thing that happens after it has to
build upon that it got it it's an
additive yeah yeah you can't go back in
time on chain and change things right
yeah immutability yeah right okay so
it's additive so
um
so actually roll ups never in a sense
decrease in size unless the compression
becomes better
they're always increasing in size in
terms yeah the state of the roll-up is
always you know over time it's
it's history is growing right yeah yeah
okay so then how does this work with the
subgraphs
what does this look like
yeah so the subgraph uh what is the
roll-up consist of with this yeah the
roll-up so it's it's looking at all of
the things that the the sub-graph
in the subgraphs uh
in the subgraph code
you you point it towards certain smart
contracts
and you say oh listen for you know
events that emitted from this smart
contract and this smart contract yes um
and then whenever those events happen
here's how you should respond here's how
you should organize your data so is the
is the roll-up a compression of the
sub-graph
it's a compression of
part of the subgraph uh that you want to
be in the roll-up
so so in our case what we're interested
in is reputation so the badges so what
badges were earned i see so you're the
roll up is
uh compression of this rep
of reputation of
subgraph
reputation yeah just the badges though
just the ones that were actually earned
like okay the stuff that you want to
take from the sub graph and put on the
blockchain
that's the stuff that's in the roll up
okay
okay cool yeah
okay um
so then i
um or any dow
can
we uniquely
program a sub-graph to monitor for
on-chain events
right and then that's rolled up
yeah that's what's rolled up yeah that's
what's compressed
yeah the actual events not not the
which events to look for like the actual
events that happen as they come in and
they happen cool and then that gets
rolled up yeah very interesting
i keep i keep seeing this as some like
ongoing like
chain
every whatever minute or
the block of the chain and then i'm
visualizing it as some sort of like a
like those thin silky hairs or something
like that are just like kind of all
pointing down
that are all like looking for those
specific on-chain events
interesting yeah yeah and then
like
uh as those are like bing bing [ __ ] like
those happened then that
is
like that's what's rolled up
and then that's again stored on chain
yeah yeah yeah there's a good way of
looking at it
interesting
and that's a sub graph this yeah
but the yeah right and the storing on
chain part the sub graph doesn't
deal with that right that's where you
were
talking about as a
an oracle that you were looking at
potentially using yeah so
right
yeah and in this uh kind of design that
i just explained the oracles would
actually be the
the indexers because they're the ones
that are attesting to the data
that is not even though it was generated
on the blockchain it was summarized in
a a way that was not defined on the
blockchain so it's
uh
it's called the computation oracle like
you are
it's an oracle in the sense that it's
providing data that's not native to the
environment that it exists in so
and then it's computation because it's
it's literally just computing
data that was derived from the
blockchain
so oracles like chain link that provide
price feeds
uh
it really is a different
architecture than what we're looking for
because we're just computing data that
was already
generated by the by the blockchain
what
in this visual that we were talking
about where the indexer is needed in
what specific
process
well the indexer is
basically responsible for making this
whole thing decentralized
so
um
the indexers are staking grt
and so if if you're going to have any
kind of assurance that an indexer's
response to a query is legitimate
uh
you need to know that they have some
kind of uh punishment if they lied right
so basically the dow still needs to work
through an indexer in this process
um
yes it needs it needs indexers indexing
their sub graph
and
it's not like they need to go find
indexers and ask them to run their
subgraph like
the graph protocol has a pretty good
system for you know they have curators
so curators are responsible for
signaling grt on sub-graphs that they
think
will become big
so anything like if you see a subgraph
and this is you know you have to kind of
know your way around web3 to understand
this stuff but
if you feel like a subgraph will have
high demand in the future and people
will be querying
indexers that are running that subgraph
then you can
stake your
signal your grt
and then if it does become big later and
many other people start curating on it
then you've now made a profit because it
uses a bonding curve so the people that
buy curation shares early buy for a
lower price then
yeah ones that buy later very
interesting so
curation is sort of like
projecting out subgraph popularity yeah
yeah exactly interesting
okay um all right so
so one of the big questions maybe that
we can
also
leave the audience with
is
what would you in your communities
look for
as
uh on-chain events that you would like
to reward
uh says soulbound labs like what i've
been talking in terms of uh the viewers
listening oh yeah so for them a question
that they would ask themselves would be
well
uh
what what would i
as a dao or as an organization what
would i want to reward
as on-chain
behavior
with badges
that would then give merit-based
access control or
reputation-based voting in my dao or
company so yeah so what would they want
to look at as on-chain behavior like for
their unique initiative
yeah it's different for every initiative
right so you have to define i mean i i
think it it ties in with your business
model like what what are the on-chain
actions that
people that have skin in the game in
your protocol
are performing and those are the ones
that
you know you want you want to award
reputation for a good example
it might be a little bit
uh too
too like crypto native but uh uniswap a
little over a year ago did a
airdrop to
users of their protocol in the past and
and
so people people that traded on uniswap
many years ago were
uh rewarded
for just using the protocol literally
just using protocol and so
oh and they also they launched a
liquidity mining pro
program so you could provide liquidity
through uniswap and then get rewarded
with this governance token uni
so one one thing that i kind of thought
of uh at the time was like oh it seems
like uh uniswap governance would want to
reward people that don't just liquidity
mine and then immediately sell the uni
token
you'd think that oh maybe that maybe it
would be more valuable to the protocol
to give people more voting power if they
liquidity mined and then held the unit
token or put the uni token in another
uniswap pool like that's the best right
if you literally take the governance
token and then put it back in the
protocol
like it doesn't get better than that
from uh
you know a protocol perspective so
it just seems like there are things that
could get rewarded
that are not already built into smart
contracts and subgraphs can be used to
reward people for those things
and hopefully years from now
many more of our real world events are
recorded on the blockchain so you can
then reward reputation for them you know
if a university is willing to
um
post on chain
who has received a diploma then
you know you can build off of that yeah
and it's all composable
okay so
we're putting
real world events on chain
and then we're having
uh
communities create subgraphs
that are looking
for specific events on chain to then
reward
uh people with badges
soul-bound nfts saying that yes we can
verify that this person did in fact
have this on-chain event or the series
of on-chain events that then yes reward
them with the soul-bound nft
yeah so so a big part of
of the future is putting
real world events on chain
and then for
communities to create sub graphs to look
for those events on chain to then reward
their community members
yeah
very cool
yeah
very cool okay
now this is great i think we did a good
job both getting into like
the division
and um big scale stuff but also
trying to get into these technical weeds
that are like man it does take a good
amount of time like going in
deep to really grok this stuff
yeah definitely
um do you feel like there are other
components
to the technicalities that you feel like
um you want to share
that could be helpful or do you feel
like
oh we did an okay job covering
that i think we did a pretty good job
covering it because it really is still
uh in development like these are things
that we're currently working on and so i
don't want to like
make any promises about oh this is how
we're designing it and then we end up
going another way you know this is all
innovative it's fun uh yeah super fun
working on this because it's a
cutting edge you know
and i like that it's flexible it's a
dynamic
it flows so
um
yeah
i do
i feel like this has been a great like
first
like this is what soul bound labs is up
to
and this is what's possible this is
what's possible to go beyond
uh
coin based governance into reputation
and merit-based governance and access
control voting
which is really cool right and right now
there's an obvious demand for this in
web 3.
but i just imagine that years from now
more data will be posted on the
blockchain from the real world and not
as a result of sold on labs or
reputation protocols
but just because there are benefits to
posting things on chain where everybody
can see it and it can't be taken down
can't be censored
so in an environment where more things
are getting put on chain then reputation
systems that are only looking at the
blockchain become much more valuable and
useful
yes
yes cool
yeah a world where reputation
and merit
systems are
constantly scanning
blockchain which is putting real world
events on on chain and then um rewarding
community
members for
that that's
yeah for for reputation for merit for
access control for voting power that
that makes i mean if it just feels like
it makes sense like in the in the heart
and the gut
uh
in the mind it really just feels like
yeah like
that makes sense and it and it protects
us from
uh like we were sharing earlier
flash loan attacks or just plutocracy or
any of the things of the past that we
can feel like no longer work for the
hole really well
um there's still too many let's say
holes or leaks or
um
attack points and
to
smooth
to smooth all of those as many of those
out as we can with uh reputation and
merit-based governance access control
is exciting
yeah
nice man
do you feel like uh anything else about
the vision or i mean i think it's
important probably to mention like
so best place to find soulbound labs is
emblemdow.com
right yes
um and you said that's your first adapt
emblem is your first adapt decentralized
application right
cool
and then that um
that has
two main things cooking right now robot
and soulbound studio right right cool
yeah so so bounce yeah go ahead you can
maybe should we explain those yeah so uh
soulbound studio is kind of this idea
for
um
a user interface for like
creating reputation with like a drag and
drop type of
flow where instead of actually writing
subgraph code you can
you can look at
at icons and drag things around and and
determine the criteria for winning a
badge
and then the idea is that once you've
once you've determined that criteria you
can click a button and it just generates
the subgraph code for you
so it really lowers the bar for so cool
creating reputation yeah
and then a robot uh
anyone that has been in web3 discord
servers knows that
there's a huge problem with uh scammers
and as soon as you join a discord server
you you get a bunch of messages from
random people pretending to be from the
team of the server you just joined and
they're
whatever they're trying to do like get
your ether whatever it is um
so
robot is a way to verify
that a discord user
also owns an account that has some
reputation attached to it so
like for example in the graphs discord
server there's an indexer channel where
all the indexers communicate about
you know upgrading their node or just
quite random questions that they have
and just being able to communicate with
each other is nice
but anybody can join that channel you
don't have to be an indexer to join it
so
there are improvements that could be
made on discord servers uh to really
just improve the quality of uh
conversation that happens there because
there is
a lot of benefit to having a platform
like discord to communicate on and the
the cleaner we can make it the better i
think so robot is then showcasing that
this uh agent in the discord server
actually has a high reputation right and
yeah it could either be access control
like you can only get in this channel if
you have these badges
or
you could also maybe like when you
respond to a message uh it shows your
badges next to your name or something
like that so that people know that the
people are talking have actually done
these things in the past yes they're not
just bullshitting yes yes
okay cool and then uh it would be good
also for you guys to check out what um
connor was mentioning about soulbound
studio to just even go and if you feel
like it on uh emblem dow you can find
this little
gui and begin like playing around with
what your
your sub graph architecture would look
like your badge reward system what that
would look like
cool
um
and so yeah emblemdao.com uh the ability
to what join the discord if it resonates
follow on twitter it's soulboundlabs
that's right right on twitter
what else are good
uh action items
um
[Music]
if you're really interested in what
we're building uh
contact us on discord i think is the
best we have we use notion and
um a lot of our kind of
uh the stuff that we're working on that
hasn't been fully developed yet is in
notion and if you're interested about
that stuff you can you can message us on
discord actually i think you can access
it just by going to
soulboundlabs.xyz that will take take
you to our notion
nice yeah
sweet so all of these links will be in
the bio below
um
so go and support if this resonated go
and support it's the best way as you
guys know
um
is to
is to join these initiatives that most
resonate with you
um and also if the video resonated with
you is like the video subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet comment below
with your thoughts on the video on what
conor's sharing around the mission and
the vision
and the implementation of it and also
share the video with others that you
feel like this idea this vision could um
positively influence and maybe even get
involved in the community
um
yeah that's i mean those are the biggest
things i'm super excited for the
continuation of soulbound and and the
vision man this is beautiful stuff it's
exciting it's been great being on yeah
and it's a powerful uh beginning to our
friendship too i'm really excited yes
it's gonna get even better tomorrow's
spike ball spike ball baby
[Music]
yeah man so excited on the beach
on the beach
in this beautiful santa cruz california
man
thanks everyone for tuning in infinite
love
and we'll catch you soon
talking